Oh was a long time ago longer now than
it seems in a place you probably saw in
a fever dream for the story you're about
to be told to place in the nyquil
induced comas evolve now you're probably
wondering where Santa Christ came from
if not I'd say well what's wrong with
you I mean doesn't this even strike it
was remotely weird
well don't worry it turns out I have an
origin story as well may not be as
interesting as say Iron Man or Stephen
Hawking but what the hell we have an old
time a narrator and a couple of bucks to
blow so here we go
Horn with the show a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away in the
not-too-distant future on a dark and
stormy night in the matrix well beyond
the town house I gave it a little
Kingdom called Egypt there was born a
very special child
his hair was his why the snow his beard
a softer Charmin his nose was as red as
a coconut wolf of wallstreet and his
cheeks as rosy as a Care Bears ass when
he laughed his belly shook like a bowl
full of coconut pudding and lo the
angels did sing on high and exclaim
foreign to us a Santa Christ is born and
many a sage and Shepherd a Magi offered
gifts of milk and cookies but all was
not well in the kingdom of Egypt for
Pharaoh her tales of this miraculous
birth and grew jealous of the child's
mighty beard and so was declared that
all children born with beards along with
in the Pharaoh shall be put to death by
electric razors Santa Christ mother
fearing for a child they afford to place
the babe in a reed basket on the banks
of long Nile there she set him free to
float down a path devoid of beard loving
tyrants away the reed basket went
falling through the deltas of the Nile
sailing through the tuna infested waters
of the Mediterranean past the Straits of
Gibraltar in unto the choppy seas of the
Atlantic long did the reed basket toss
and turn in the waves of the great sea
but no crying did Santa Christ make just
a gentle
ohoho in the middle of the Atlantic the
basket was picked up in the city of
Atlantis but the Atlanteans fearful that
they'd anger their guard threw the
basket back into the water
this in turn a Gerber guard in the city
was sunk after 40 days and 40 nights the
basket eventually washed up on the snowy
sheets of the North Pole there the child
was discovered by coca-cola drinking
polar bears who took pity on him and
taught him the ways of the bear bear he
learned to sled play with penguins ride
the icebergs and after it was all done
share refreshing iced cold coca-cola
with his fellow cops but it wasn't to
last for eventually his father Paul Kent
that's P aww in case you were wondering
kicked the coke bottle after succumbing
to adult onset diabetes from drinking
too much coke Santa Christ was
despondent Oh my sugary powers and I
couldn't save him
do not cry said his mother for your an
out of this world what do you mean
you're not a bear but what about my
white hair that's a beard and my love of
coke sugar addiction my fur that's
actually Uncle Frank's skin he tried to
eat you when you first arrived cuz he's
a bear and we sometimes eat our young
because we're bad so that burger meat
you've been feeding me enough questions
yeah we found this in your basket
it's a glowing peppermint rod we figured
when the time was right you'd know what
to do so I do Santa cry said but after
many months of beating other thing he
realized he had no clue what to do with
it so he tossed it into the frozen waste
and lo a mighty candy cane Castle rose
from the ice a fortress of sucrose awed
by its minty immensity since
christ-centered there he placed his
magic peppermint rod in a glowing mug of
charged hot chocolate and then a mighty
face appeared who are you I am Jehovah
one true gobloon yes and Who am I you
are my one true conception my son born
it to bring peace on earth and goodwill
to children and how do I do that
by fulfilling your destiny yes destiny
of half laid out before you where you
fulfill role a role which you are
destined to repeat again and again and
again and the sounds kind of redundant
trust me
you can make a great living and so was
that chief over the one Chuco bloom
instructed Santa Christ in the ways of
chaos acting rambling ranting talking in
circles placing your time laughs at
inappropriate intervals until at last
Santa Christ could disarm anyone with
his confusing charm and so his training
complete he received the candy cane
staff of peppermint power and was sent
out into the world
for three years he wanted to cross the
globe before geing many friendships with
powers great and small and his love of
pancakes grew
we're not spreading his word he saved
kittens and stuff I don't know there's
some pages missing if we try actually
reading the Bible Doctor Who is better
continuity but almost not well for the
Dark Lord Satan had gotten word that
there was a new player in town and he
was not to have known to where but he
had a plan to corrupt the children of
the world and it was video games
disguised as young tech-savvy CEO he
traveled from company to company
teaching them about updated graphics
faster processing technology an engaging
gameplay but they were all deceived for
deep in the bowels of Silicon Valley he
forged the counsel of his own and into
it he poured his malice his hatred and
his will to dominate all the children of
Earth the Philips CDI the master console
with this console children would be
fooled by snazzy full motion video web
browsing new Zelda games and online play
so much so that they'd sell their souls
for it which admittedly was far cheaper
than the $700 starting price I mean come
on that's like 1,100 bucks in today's
money one by one the children of the
earth fell to Satan's way and he left on
his throne of blood in Gary Indiana but
there were some who resisted sent Christ
d respect Cory the red horn or wall
caught wind of Satan's burn and flew to
sent Christ's secret hideout horrified
by what he heard he mounted his sled and
called out to his flying narwhals on
Campbell on Ramey on curly and Larry on
champey on Trumpy and don't forget
Marvin Harry using secret hyper Jets to
aid the tired narwhals through the
castle run they flew past the moons of
Vega round and round the moons of Libya
and Taurus Maelstrom and partitions fame
to last they broke the Tannhauser gate
and cross the Rainbow Bridge into the
Northern Lights of Ihara
there in the midst of the aurora
borealis the narwhals falls into the
secret meeting place the International
House of Pancakes at the center of the
universe next to the Starbucks there was
assembled the League of Extraordinary
awesomeness abraham lincoln queen
elizabeth pikachu Sacagawea
Crocodile Hunter Steve Irwin Godzilla
mother Teresa Wolverine Bill Nye the
Science Guy in the 1985 Chicago Bears
there were a feast of french toast and a
rooty tooty fresh and fruity meal they
debated the fate of all earth pikachu
suggested a surprise attack on Pearl
Harbor but this was voted down as being
mostly irrelevant mother Teresa
suggested helping the poor but that
seemed too boring Bill Nye the Science
Guy suggested total thermal nuclear
warfare
but that seemed a little hasty finally
their bottomless cups of coffee
exhausted and the syrup suppliers
running though Santa Christ stood up
with a plate of unfinished french toast
my fellow Guardians take my french toast
bread and eat it for it was given unto
you cinnamon swirls and all because I
much prefer pancakes and then he passed
around a pitcher of coke and said this
is my Cola which I have given up for you
drink it and be caffeinated and they did
eat and drink of his brandy Cola and
then he said know that you are all
stopped
let me speak freely tonight one of you
will accidentally betray me is it I
asked Wolverine yes actually and it was
a long and cup double silence hey you
asked but it doesn't matter we should
face Satan not with a sucker punch but
on a field of honorable combat and then
with a wrinkle of his nose and a wink of
his eye he smother 1985 bears running
back Walter Payton perhaps again so was
decided the League of Extraordinary
awesomeness which Alan Satan to a game
of american football and so Satan never
wonder pass up a challenge
agreed to the bet should the league win
the CD I would be pulled from shelves
but should they lose the other consoles
will become Satan's forever and the
league would be forced to star in the
number of unsuccessful M night Shyamalan
films a fate worse than death
Vidia was made a football game in
another realms of Candyland played on
live dinosaurs Satan took a
motherfucking t-rex Santa Bryce grabbed
a fleshy us or which was kind of
difficult since they have fins but it
was no less difficult than for Godzilla
who had to ride himself making matters
worse Satan assembled a team of his most
evil minions there was a head of Hitler
Joseph Stalin Caligula Rupert Murdoch
Harvey Levin in the writers of TMZ
non-hodgkins lymphoma and the 2014 New
England Patriots with history's greatest
cheating quarterback Tom Brady together
they were known as the Hells Angels and
that was much scarier name than Santa
Christ team the snowflakes but who cares
they were writing motherfucking
dinosaurs and they're on the slopes of
the big rock candy mountain they fought
for the freedom of all earth the first
quarter started off all as Crocodile
Hunter Steve Irwin accidentally scored
touchdown for the opposition three
timeouts wasted as team flag had to
explain the rules of American football
to their Australian counterpart second
quarter no better mother Teresa out with
the torn meniscus score Hells Angels at
as Grimm eres coach Mike Ditka tried to
inspire his team with a well-placed by a
grad third quarter things of dark Tom
Brady ready throw that's how I know
he'll yell but to play that is falling
apart like a flaccid penis Sacagawea
picks it up a touchdown flakes fourth
quarter near the end things were
desperate tie game at the two-minute
warning the lead substitute their secret
weapon Wolverine and he unleashed his
tornado claw but he missed in Santa Cruz
first our Father forgive me knows not
what he does and so it was that perhaps
he came to pass in Santa Christ fell and
there was a clap of lightning a
Wolverine screamed although three
seconds later Santa Christ worse can
have filmed up the awesomeness and then
Bears quarterback Jim McMahon snapped
his arm back but no Hitler forces a
fumble and he flies into the hands of
Alta Payton who shouts Hail Marys Santa
Christ and he throws the ball to the end
zone with Santa Christ is still rising
from the dead and lo skies opened up the
Sun did shine and the Angels rang out in
the glorious Alleluia as Santa Christ
caught the ball with the hairs of his
prehensile beard and yeah there was much
rejoicing for man and dinosaur the Bears
did do the Super Bowl shuffle so the
great console wars had ended as for the
CDI it disappeared into total obscurity
never to be heard from again
except in top-10 listless in YouTube
videos showcasing really crappy zelda
footage look up CDI zelda cutscenes yo
saw will be hilariously crushed
soon return to hell and assumed the form
of michael eisner there he ran a
director video scheme for the Walt
Disney Company while licking his wounds
for his service in the cosmic Super Bowl
Santa Christ returned his precioso to
the waters of Loch Ness where the
monster retired and lived a happy life
photobombing Scottish Taurus but for
jolly st. Christ there was a certain
unease tired and despondent he returned
to his fortress of sucralose and spoke
with his Heavenly Father Jehovah I have
defeated Satan and yet my heart is
troubled for the kids now have no games
to turn to no consoles to play no
electronics to babysit their fragile
little box the answer was
for there was a alright his system which
fulfill all their needs something good
something pure not an end but beginning
Oh Gemma sense your instincts out
serving will my son go now give them the
power of 16-bits give them the speed of
7.2 megahertz CPU I changed the console
change the world and thus it came to
pass and every Christmas Eve Santa
Christ would ride with his nine narwhal
and pass out Sega Genesis to all the
young girls and boys said they were no
sooner forget what transpired long ago
when the world was consumed in the great
console war and if you listen closely on
a dark and starry night you might hear
him with a twinkle in his eye and a
belly full of pudding shouting merry
Genesis to all and remember to eat your
freaking pancakes well there it is don't
look at me I don't think it makes any
freaking sense either
[Laughter]
you